um welcome everybody
um
at the Don't Panic talk I hope everybody
is aware that this is a talk about uh
kanban and some agility and about flow
so if you're here to learn about
development uh I'm sorry I'm not going
to help you there but although I have
been a developer once I will introduce
myself in a minute
um so it's going to be a talk about the
Learning Zone and the comfort zone and
the Panic Zone and how the kanban
maturity model is going to help you with
that and I'm a common coach so this is
uh this is the work I'm I'm living in
and that's that's why I'm going to talk
about it
um I'm Martin hoppen I'm a drummer uh
I'm a vapor uh still doing a bit of
vaping
I think it's better than snooze but you
never know
um and I um I'm an intermittent faster
so that's why there's a bottle a box of
fruit and yogurt in the in the corner
and I also like to do some some hobby
video editing but that's not my uh my my
big business
and as you see there's a lot of sticky
notes on the wall I'm completely
addicted to Sticky Notes
um like every agilist and therefore
covet was a very terrible time because
we all went digital and now I left all
my sticky notes at home so that's the
idea
um as I said I'm an agile coach I work
at VX company that's a company in the
Netherlands not a very big company like
300 people or something we do a lot of
development and I'm also an accredited
kanban trainer at the common University
so I teach a number of kanban trainings
the common courses and I'm a
professional scrum trainer at scrum.org
and I did data scrimmaster training as a
workshop in the beginning of this week
so Monday and Tuesday and yes I have
been a developer in the past and I
started with COBOL so I even created a
lot of Legacy code
that you're trying to fix now I guess
and then I went into the Java rearm and
I did some groovy and Ruby but then I
pretty much passed out because I
couldn't handle it anymore and I took I
took the the hints for granted that I
was more like a people person than the
technical person although I always
thought I was going to be lead architect
or something but after a number of years
people kept telling me that was not the
case I thought well then it might be a
good idea to stop being technical
um and that's when I when I went into
the whole actual coaching thing and
that's what I'm doing now for about 14
years so I'm uh I'm pretty seasoned at
the moment and I've seen a lot of stuff
and uh maybe people went to the Billy
Holly's uh uh talk yesterday uh that
that was nice but I think the one he did
the evening before Tuesday evening at
the
norwegian.net use a group uh Meetup uh
he had a very nice talk also about that
actually I was going to go away and
those kind of things but he had some
very interesting thinking and I'm very
in favor of that because I'm a pragmatic
agilist I think
scrum is not the Silver Bullet Gumball
is not the Silver Bullet extreme
programming it's not Silver Bullet so I
always think that you should take the
pragmatic approach and always pick stuff
from the toolbox that you need and also
don't use stuff because they tell you so
only use it because you think it's going
to work and it really helps you in your
context so that's that's who I am
um
does any one of you don't know what
kumbun is
oh everybody knows that's cool
um
then I'm I'm going to
quickly go through it because I want to
make make sure that everybody's on the
same page the common method is not
a project management method so it's not
a method to do project management and
it's not a software delivery management
method so it's uh for life cycle
management or something like that
I think most of you know common as
having stickies on the wall or a
different visual digital board and
having a to-do doing down lane or maybe
a number of more Lanes or columns in
there
and that's probably part of common or at
least common is using a lot of that
stuff it's about visualization
but for in essence a common is a
management method
for directly improving Your Service
delivery it's catalyzing that
Improvement and it's trying to evolve
your business to be fit for purpose so
common is much more a change management
method than it is a project management
or a process delivery message method or
something like that yeah
and why why come on came to life is
pretty much because
um we we all hope that when we do a
change we are starting at some level so
you're here and then we do the
transition and we aim to go for the
higher goal and we all we we hope that
the transition is going to be with
starting here we're going up and now
we're on the high level but that is
never the case the case is that reality
is more like this it's like the the
Jayco from satir you probably know it
and the the problem from uh from the J
curve is that there's a lot of uh
resistance going on and if if if the the
change is taking too much time or is
going to too deep into the change you
need a lot of organizational uh
resistance or a tolerance to accept a
change and uh when we do a big change in
agiles on agile transformation and doing
like safe or a real real complete
implementation of scrum I think we see
we see that the big system change and we
call that in lean terms we call that
kaikaku h
as agileist and lean person the more
Japanese terms you know the higher on
the ladder of hierarchy so so I I will I
will name a number of them so then you
know that I'm one uh no but kaikaku
that's that's one of them and what we
prefer in the kanban world is doing
smaller steps so having the smaller
steps to improve and that's what we call
probably you know it uh Kaizen yeah so
that's that's what we see
[Music]
um
there are a number of change principles
in common there's change principles and
Service delivery principles but because
it's about change I think I'm going to
name them first
and let's start with what you do now
um and that means with everything you've
got in place or your processes your
roles your functions your working
agreements we're not going to start
changing them we're first going to start
where you are now and making them
visible and visualize them and then
we're going to aim for evolutionary
change so small steps continuously
improving and we want to stimulate
leadership in all levels and at the end
of the talk I will come back a little
bit to the leadership thing because I
think the essence of all changes are
based on the right leadership that's in
your organization
but get rid of the leaders and put the
right leaders in there is probably a
difficult thing so we need to change
them a bit up differently yeah then next
to the change uh
principles we also have got Service
delivery principles and I think people
who know lean know these principles
pretty okay focus on the customer so
start with the customer in mind manage
your work your flow yeah let the people
self-organize around it that's like an
agile thinking and we want to develop
and improve the working agreements in in
common we call them explicit policies so
something to know about
the last one that I wanted to touch upon
what come on this is the six practices
that common is delivering us and that's
uh that's that's uh that's the I think
it was the first time it was written
down was by uh David Anderson in the
blue book kanban book evolutionary
change for your service delivery
business and he came up with six
practices and that's official wise
physical wise your work I'm sorry I'm
sorry uh so uh what what you probably do
also if you do scrum or extreme
programming or if you're using uh Azure
devops or adolescent or something you
visualize your work
um because every work
item every everything you do in your
life probably has some kind of workflow
so you can visualize that workflow we're
trying to limit our work in progress
limit your whip
we manage the flow of work in that case
and we try to create explicit policies
probably in your if you are using scrum
you're doing a definition of done you've
got other explicit policies but you can
also think about
pool options pull rules
when are we what color of stickies are
we going to use for specific work
categories and those kind of things so
those are explicit policies we're going
to use feedback loops although kanban
doesn't really Define any real meetings
except the daily meeting the common
meeting other meetings are not really
explicitly in there but we want to have
feedback loops and the essence is to
improve collaboratively and evolutionary
yeah so doing experiments Fail-Safe
experiments because that's what we we
are doing where we're evolutionary
thinking method
okay so now everybody's on par with what
compound is yeah and I do I do this this
this part I do in a two days training so
I don't know why I did it just in a few
minutes
uh that's that's a bad man uh marketing
I think
um
Next Step
the reasons at at least what's my on the
title uh that's the two reasons why uh a
lot of agile Transformations fail or
stall and I think uh I think you will
all have come across them I probably
probably you do at least who is doing
some kind of agile in their organization
yeah I think pretty much everybody a few
not but
um what
some kind of HR indeed yeah yeah then
it's if you just mention the world word
then it's already agile isn't it
um and what we see is two kinds of uh of
failure and that's the overreaching
failure and the full Summit plateau and
um the overreaching failure is pretty
much we are aiming too high
and we're not able to to uh to get that
done are we okay with a low mediocre
level of performance and those two are
pretty much always the case or at least
sometimes not but and what we see in the
overreaching is that the kaikaku so the
big change
uh goes over the heads of most of the
people and that's where we have that
deep investment big investment a lot of
organizational tolerance is needed and
the bigger and the longer it's it is the
more problematic it is and what I see is
that and I think I've been one of those
persons some Somewhere in Time that I
was really bragging about how cool stuff
I could do with agile so I came across
uh teams that were trying to do some
agility and then I came with the highest
high-end definitions of agile and doing
new stuff and Innovations and talking
with other retro coaches about how cool
this stuff is and that doesn't matter
because it's about the team it's about
the ones you are going to help so that's
a very bad bad stance for a natural
coach a natural coach should always be
servant and the servant leader towards
the organization and the people so
always be humble and Nimble about what
you're doing so I think that's something
that I've learned a lot in the last
couple of years
um and the problem is if this happens is
that
um the organization is not going to be
able to
fix that change and at One Moment In
Time the sale it doesn't doesn't deliver
any results so the improvements stay out
and they decide to stop the change they
panic and they go with another change
and then they go into a downward spiral
because the next change will probably
also deliver a J curve in satir's terms
so that's a problem
um the other one is the fall Summit
and that's where people say well this is
probably the best we can do and we feel
comfortable with it so we ex we accept
uh that level of performance and that's
probably mediocre if we don't step more
um does anybody know how much time
Toyota took to uh to become like 75 of a
performance increase from the beginning
do you know any does anybody know
shouted a number of years
10 I hear
80 years so Toyota says we've got 80
years to improve 75 percent of what's
possible yeah so if you think that after
a year or two years or three years
you're done with your improvements
I always say thing again of course
that's why we as your coaches still at
work but um but that's that's also that
I think that's an important uh knowledge
uh things are always changing you should
always be committing to the change and
helping and embracing that change and so
the context is is futile there so always
try to to improve I think that's an
important part and don't stop too often
too and too early
um so they think they assume they have
reached their Summit the the on top and
they just kettle on and that's good and
we see a lot of resignation then and
lack of urgency and lack of uh challenge
so
to recurse one more
um communist evolutionary change doing
small steps in Kaizen step by step by
step
but the biggest question then is how do
we initiate though that's that
continuous small step of improvement and
small step of change and I think that's
the biggest the biggest question we have
to address here
um and that's where my first subtitle
comes from and that's about the Learning
Zone so
um uh people who do
um Sports coaching or uh uh teaching
music instruments or something like that
or being a teacher at school or at
someone else but if you do something
like that or you're being a coach and
you're at your work
um You probably all have to have to do
something like this and that's getting
people into the Learning Zone in the
stretch Zone and
um what we see in in that in that area
is that there are pretty much three
zones you've got your comfort zone your
Learning Zone or stretch Zone and your
Panic Zone and the Learning Zone is our
sweet spot of improvement that's the
place where we learn the most we achieve
the most we we improve ourselves in the
company and your team and those kind of
things and therefore as a sports coach
or as a instrument teacher but also as a
agile coach we are trying to get
everybody in that Learning Zone or the
whole company even in the Learning Zone
um does anybody know
um the cartoon from I think it's from
Disney from The Croods
yeah that's with the the caveman uh with
uh shrock I think he's called the father
of the Familia
um and he uh he he keeps them all in a
cave so we've got a we've got a cave
with uh with them in there and he uh
he's always protecting them so he keeps
them in the safe Zone in the comfort
zone and uh the idea of a at your coach
or a a kanban coach is to get them out
of that comfort zone that safe Zone and
get them into the Learning Zone so
that's also what he does so he he get
away that that rock he lose them into uh
the Comfort oh no and then something
happens and I think that's the biggest
problem so we get into a panicky moment
and the Panic is that there are big
monsters a lot of uh diseases going on
in there and uh so if you get them in
the Panic Zone the biggest problem is
that they will get into that cave again
and they will stay there for longer that
they didn't then they've been there
before so Panic creates uh fear and
anxiety and uh it creates a flight uh
movement and you will fly it into your
comfort zone again and you will stay
there for longer than you did before so
I think it's a very important part as
being a coach or a trainer or a teacher
to avoid getting them into the Panic
zone so that's that's that's one of the
parts that's part of what we're I'm
going to tell you
um and the kanban maturity model is
going to help you with that that's the
idea behind it
so um let's uh kmm that's the common
maturity model and we call that an ECM
an evolutionary change model so we're
all about evolutionary change so small
steps kaizen-like changes
and the common maturity model declares
three aspects and I'm not sure if I have
to cover all of them but we're going to
dive a bit more into the practices in a
while but these are the three aspects of
camera maturity model so we've got
culture and that's this is how we live
here this is the value and the
principles of the organization sometimes
written sometimes not written but a lot
of it is defined by behavior and actions
that are taken there yeah
um then you've got the outcomes
um and that is the demonstration of the
results this is uh how how a business
looks like this is how the outside world
sees us so that those are the outcomes
and um the practices are the parts that
we that's how we do things around here
so that's what we put into practice and
those are routine activities observable
patterns and those kind of things so
this is also where we talk about the
practices of common so what we talked
about just about a few minutes ago the
six practices like visualize work in
progress limits and those kind of things
those are in that area yeah so those are
practices
um and now I'm going to show you the
model itself Don't Be Afraid Don't Panic
it is a big one and probably not
readable from behind and that's
perfectly okay because I'm going to
break it down in much simpler pieces so
we've got the cultural side and of
values the cultural values then we've
got the maturity levels and they start
with zero and we think that everybody
already is at zero but if you think
you're not then we have the first step
to make and it goes up until six and uh
six is like
um
uh not not interesting enough and five
also to to talk about yet but the first
three or four are probably the most
interesting to look at and on the right
side you see the six practices the
visualize limit web manage flow and
those kind of things yeah and I'm going
to walk through uh very quickly through
the maturity levels and uh the maturity
levels are on the left side for you and
we start with zero and we call that
oblivious so
um it's all based on achievement
individual achievement individual
results
um does anybody use any any kind of a
common system for themselves like a
personal common or something to do doing
done lists or to-do lists
yeah a number of people do that
um that's that's when you're in a team
and you're still having your own
personal common lifts that's pretty okay
I think it's also very good for your
personal uh productivity Effectiveness
and Effectiveness and efficiency but uh
when we want to go into a team we need
to work together uh the the thing of uh
the the how do you call it a team one
plus one is three that idea is probably
also true so if you want to become a
team we have to work together and then
Personal Achievement is not the only
thing what it's all about it's also
about togetherness so that's that's the
next step we we think the first step
that we need to take if we don't have
that already is becoming a team so
having a team focused common system and
a lot of practices on the right side I'm
going to dive in them a bit more lately
later
um but it's about uh collaboration uh
talking together initiatives and those
kinds of things and of course if we have
to work together we have to be
transparent so transparency is also part
of it
um so those are the first two the the
oblivious person will come bomb and then
we go into a team-focused environment
and I think that's the first step most
agile environments already take
then the second step that's the customer
driven I think uh like uh scrum and safe
and all those agile methods are trying
to deliver something that's all about
customer driven and trying to deliver
something that the customer cares for
and then we get uh processes that are
efficient and consistent but the
outcomes will probably not be yet then
we need some good uh prioritization a
good product owner and those kind of
things but here we see most of the
kanban practices or values come into
play like the acts of leadership
customer awareness evolutionary change
flow so all all of them are kanban and
lean values that we already know
um we also see delivery common and
Discovery come on here and that's what
some people also call upstream and
downstream customer kanban developer
common or something so we already got
something in play there with two two
types of common systems working together
and having an upstream flow with your
um with your uh product backlogs and the
downstream flow with your Ops or
something like that so there is
something going on there already
and then in the third step and I might
say something about the fourth is the
fit for purpose step and that's where we
really try to have consistent outcomes
so also having your customer involved in
your feedback loops and getting uh
getting getting to meeting expectations
and having service delivery or service
level expectations or something like
that and there is what we see that we we
have like the values of agreement
balance customer service all those terms
so this is this is where I think most of
our agile practices are trying to aim
for this is where we want to what one
want to achieve the next step I'm not
going to dive much more into that one is
the risk hatched model and that's where
we not only do it right at the moment so
we do we have a good uh a good good
thing going on but it's also being
prepared for the future so risk hatch
means that you already know the risks of
the future that you look up up ahead
five years up front or something and
that that's what what is all part of
that process so that's that's much more
mature than most organizations are doing
I think if you if you reach level three
then uh you're pretty happy uh as most
organizations
five and six Market Leaf were built for
survival uh in the book of uh the common
maturity model that David wrote uh with
also a lot of audit definitions in there
you can read more about it but the only
one who is teaching this is David
himself uh and it's uh that's okay for
me
okay as I said we've got six practices
um the visualize practices so that's the
first one then we've got limit whip
manage flow make policies explicit
feedback loops and improve
collaboratively and experimentally
um I'm going to do some examples later
on I will focus on the visualizing the
limit width so that you understand what
it's all about
um but this this is the model so this is
the big model that we we use the common
maturity model level level model for
maturity model four
um
what's also interesting is that you see
um at least I'm going to step one back I
think that's good and then I have to
step forward again you see the one and
then the one two uh the zero to one and
then you see the one and the one two two
so those are different different steps
within that same level and we call them
the transition and consolidation
practices so those are two different
practices and uh what's interesting
about those practices is that
um if you have transition practices
those practices will be more like
visualizing making people aware and you
can you can push a little so that's
that's where trainers and coaches are
doing are giving a little bit of
stressors so getting people out of their
comfort zone making them aware that they
can achieve a bit more so that we can we
can tickle them and make make them aware
that they can do something that's that's
where it's okay as a coach to to push a
bit yeah so that's that's okay when you
go into the consolidation practices
that's where we want to come consolidate
the next we call it equilibrium so the
next level where we want to balance
that's the place where we want to
consolidate and that's that's getting
probably more resistance because we have
to create new rules new agreements we
have to fix items and that's that's the
moment where as a coach and as a trainer
we need to let them pull so we we are
going to offer them practices but we're
not going to push them in so that's an
important part so we push to stress make
them aware make them visualize make them
understand that something else can be
better and then when when they make that
step to become better then we offer them
practices to make sure that they they
consolidate that level that new
equilibrium they're in so what you see
in this model is uh the the zero to one
the one one to two so those are the
transition level practices transition
level one level two level three and
those are different practices than the
practices that were on this on the
second part and that's the consolidation
practices and they they both do just
what I said
um
as a common coach and I'm going to
stress it once more
um we are the engine of that
evolutionary change
and I think it's important oh this is my
drawing yeah I did some drawing
um we are not a puppet master so we're
not going to uh play with them as dolls
we are going to be servant leaders so
it's very important to to become a
servant leader and to offer them help
and to facilitate them and you're not
going to be the one that's directing the
change you're going to facilitate the
change and that's an important part
uh do people know the UDA Loop that's
here UDA that's uh observe Orient decide
and act
and I think that's pretty much much the
the scheme you are working in as a as a
coach so you always observe what is
happening you're going to look into the
working agreements and the working
environments and the models they are
using and the practices they are using
at the moment and uh that's where you
know and understand what is happening
and with that understanding you're going
to make the next step and you're going
to look into okay if this is the level
they're at now
then let's say they're at level one
then we are not going to create or push
practices that are level three or four
or five because they they don't accept
it they will get into the Panic Zone
then so the first thing you have to do
is look into the practices that are
going to help you to be to step into the
next maturity level so the next level of
practices
and if you know that then that's what
you're going to do and if it's in
transition level you're going to push it
a bit and if it's in the consolidation
level you're going to offer them those
practices and when they have implemented
them then you can look again so it's a
constant revisiting of that Loop that
Ula Loop of where are we now how can we
decide what to do now and then act on it
so that's the constant Loop that we need
to go through
now I've got two examples uh and uh I
did some webinars and I'm sorry they're
in Dutch uh is there anyone in the room
who understands Dutch
okay yeah a bit okay so you can look at
it probably and then understand what's
happening the others are just uh then
like probably gray noise to to get to
sleep or something that's good but um if
I I might do an English version if if I
get enough response for this uh this
session
um but I've got two two examples and
it's it's about uh the common for teams
a webinar and uh I did a common
one-on-one first to make everybody
understand and the first part I did was
a bit about that that come on 101 and in
that common for teams there are
different levels of uh team kombbomb and
we're going to look into two two parts
of them and uh the first one is going to
be the the whip limits per person so
that's pretty much like a personal
kanban thing gather together aggregated
personal Compound on one board and
everybody has got their own stuff to do
and they're not really working together
um so this is a whip limit per person
and
um it's it's one step from personal
Gumball so they can work together but
they have their own whip limits and what
we see here is uh on top we call that an
unlimited work in progress so uh it's uh
it's however how much you want to put in
that column that's okay that's not a
real pool system because a pool system
needs a work in progress limit to make
sure that we can use Little's law if
people know the Little's law from
networking or something that's also the
same Little's law we need a limit
because otherwise we cannot manage the
flow in the system and what we also see
is there are people on the bench so
those are avatars or something on the
bench and we have got orphan items so
items that are not
owned by anyone and that's probably not
a good thing so these items are waiting
there and nobody's working on them at
the moment so they're they're just there
and I don't know what it is but that's
that's what that's what the case is yeah
I'm not sure if this is readable but
I'll help out a bit
um so what we see in that board is that
we have at least we have got some
visualization of the work yeah so we see
several individuals and they have some
kind of a aggregated individual common
mode so personal Gumball on one word
with a number of people
we see avatars they are using avatars in
that system so that looks like uh like
like that level and we see a per person
whip limit and how can we see that
that's like the number of avatars you
have per person so let's say everybody
has got three avatars and they can put
on the board and if your avatars are
empty so you don't have anybody on the
bench anymore then you cannot do any
more work so you've got a per person
whip limit that case
uh so I think we can safely assume based
on visualize and limiting Whip and of
course there are a number of other
practices that are also in play but we
can safely assume that they are at least
at the transition phase from zero to one
yeah so that will be it and therefore we
can look at how can we improve uh
visualize work by the whole team and not
by persons to create a real kanban board
and a team come on board and we want to
make some more uh basic policies and I
think the last one and I think that's
the most important one is to establish
some kind of a team whip limit so now
we've got uh unlimited columns and
that's a bad thing if you want to create
a pool system so I think it's a good
idea to to bring them into that that
environment so we offer them those items
and we will see what they think will be
the best things to do yeah so this is
this is from zero to one and stepping
into the the the the first one a
maturity level
the next one is more like an aggregated
team come on I'm sure that a lot of you
are in this uh environment we see two
teams team one is doing development and
team two is doing testing or we've got
an analyzers team and a development team
or a development team and a deployment
team so two teams that are in the same
workflow with a customer asking asking
for something and then going through a
number of teams at In This Moment too
delivering something in the end and um
and those teams are working together
with a column in the middle and that
column in the middle is the done column
and that one is also not limited and
therefore we have got two common systems
we call that because if you've got an
unlimited column in the middle
then we have a decoupled system because
both systems can have some
predictability but they have to work
with each other and that that unlimited
column in the middle can be as long as
what as you want so that will not be
predictable so that's that's why it's a
decoupled system and we've got two
common systems in this way you can also
say we've got two moments we can commit
so we commit in the next column and we
commit in the column before testing
that's also commitment point
uh what we also see is something like a
next column so that does mean they have
something like
um in in scrum we will probably call
that the the Sprint backlog so we we
pulled stuff in from a product backlog
into a Sprint backlog and the next
column at least means something this is
the next highest priority to take up
yeah so there is something some
prioritization going on
and we have got something like it says
P1
so Priority One or something like a buck
or a defect or an impediment or
something that's going on so they at
least we see more than one type of work
so there are more work categories going
on
um so if we if we are trying to
translate this to the common maturity
model we see in that model a number of
things we see that uh at level two to
three so transitioning from two to three
they already have something like a
commit status so that's the next column
that we've seen yeah so there's a
there's something that we are going to
commit to working on and like the spring
backlog I said they've got a workflow
that's based on teams
um but they are not coupled yet so
they've got two teams aggregated
compound so that's there 1.3 and we've
got uh the first steps on limiting whip
with the aggregated surface so they have
got their own whip limits but I think
it's a good idea to also look into
couple them and have a limit on that
unlimited column at first
what I also see is
um but I'm not sure I it looks like
there is a failure demand or a different
type of work in that system so I have to
investigate it a bit more we have to
talk to the to the team and have to find
out is this really what you you are
using is this a different working
category or something so there is some
kind of failure demand and value demand
going on so that's also interesting to
see so what we can assume here is that
they are in transition to from one to
from two to three but they are not there
yet we see a lot of stuff that's not
done especially the right column of
visualization is not there yet so we
probably have to focus a bit more on
that and push a bit there and if that's
going right then we have to go and to
have some activity-based whip limits and
then we can probably step into the next
environment of fit for purpose so then
get into the next level of maturity
okay
um
so what do we have now
we have
an environment that the common maturity
model offers us I'm going to
step almost in the concluding
and kanban is helping us as coaches and
as change managers and as servant
leaders if you want to call it like that
is going to help us to achieve what is
the level of maturity or what is the
level of confidence that the
organization the teams the individuals
in the organization have
and we can talk with them about can we
do a bit more so if we're in transition
we can can push a bit and we can see
that what is too high level for them so
we can not use because then they will
become in panic but if we offer them
stuff that they already do then they are
too confidently so we have to find out
how we can push them a bit into that
zone of learning so the Learning Zone
and the stretch Zone and that's what the
common maturity model really tries to do
so although it sounds like an auditing
model and I think it is
um and I'm not happy with that
especially not specifically at least but
okay if nobody else is offering it then
someone else's and I think it's better
if we offer it ourselves if we are in
the kambon University
um but for me the most important thing
is that the common maturity model really
helps coaches and trainers and teachers
in organizations to think about how can
we help people get out of that comfort
zone into the Learning Zone so I think
that's the the most important part of it
so if we
look into that first slide again don't
panic so the goal is not to to make them
panic I think I would have stopped this
uh this video a bit earlier so because
they were still panicking and that's not
a good idea and as I mentioned up front
uh I would like to uh have a have a
small a little talk about leadership
and that's because this is the three
aspects is also has come together in a
mantra and that Mantra is outcomes
follow practices practices follow
culture and culture follows values and
therefore we have to lead with with
values and what's interesting is that um
if we if we want to change the behavior
in your organization then practices are
a good idea to start with so you can
look at practices you can Implement
practices because they will influence
the outcomes
and but before you can change practices
we also have to change
culture and the biggest problem of
culture is that it's not not really
changeable there's not there are not
really dials that you can can can can
how do you call it pool or something
like that
to change the culture so culture is
driven by behavior and by actions by
leaders and I think one of one of the um
I've got it somewhere here yeah it's a
good one so this is this is the
definition of culture
um this is the uh the the sum of values
times the actions the behavior of of the
leaders that's what drives culture so if
we really want to change organizations
then
um I think it's very important to also
have the leaders involved and have them
commit to that change and have them work
out the change in the system
um
but I think that is a topic for a whole
other
talk so I think that's what we want to
conclude with
and therefore
um
I always have two slides at the end
there is a time for Q a and no time for
Q a but uh because there's still time I
think there's there's a possibility to
do some q a if someone has any questions
no ah yeah okay come on
okay as well yeah
you have everything
like things that
so the question is how do we visualize
everything and the question of course is
what do you mean with everything so
let's revisit that one in a moment
because there is a lot of going on in
the in the team and you cannot visualize
everything and then you mean like
incidents and production disturbances so
smaller items
all the things that the team is supposed
to do that's not a delivery
hmm
I would so so things that you're talking
about things that's outside of the
delivery board and part of helping other
teams or other someone comes along asks
you something you have to help them
um for me as a coach or a monista I
always say everything you do is work and
we should make everything visible and
transparent I understand that every
small question putting it on a sticky
note or somewhere in a in a system is
going to take much more Administration
than the work you're doing on it so
probably that's not a good idea but then
I at least want to see how much of your
time are you doing because of ordinary
questions Incident Management doing
males doing phone calls so I want to
know what the capacity of the team is
addressed by with other stuff than the
stuff that we have on the board and I
would I would make sure that there is
capacity for it the the biggest thing I
always see is that people say well I I
don't put a put a put a ticket on the
wall for an item that only cost me like
half an hour or 15 minutes or something
but if you've got 30 of them per day
then you don't do anything else anymore
so what are you doing then are you still
working because I think it's work so
make sure that you put all the work on
the board and if you say well that the
cost too much too much Administration
then at least have some kind of of a
voting system that you know how much
time you put in that that kind of work
so I think I would put probably
everything on the board but be aware of
that Administration part yeah
good enough
not yet okay come on trigger me some
more
uh there's a advice read team topologies
and I think that's that's a good idea
that's about how you structure your
organization or your teams with value
driven I think stream aligned teams they
call them and you've got platform teams
and you've got uh enabling teams and I
think complex subsystems teams I think
they're called so those are the four
they have but indeed if you have
multiple teams working together
um
if you did anybody go to the to the the
talk last night from uh ah was he called
I wrote it down James Lewis he did the
flow with Lego game
um and he he talked about the whole flow
uh environment and he said optimize the
whole make sure that because if if
multiple teams are working on the same
system delivering the same stuff to the
customer it's all about bottleneck
management within so the critical path
through all those teams and then also if
you are working for other teams that are
more critical than you are then I think
it's okay but if you are the critical
person on the critical path of the
system so the bottleneck of the system
then you should not be the one who is
disturbed because you are delivering
something that's important and the whole
system is relying on your productivity
and therefore you have more value
and therefore you're a valuable person
everybody's a valuable person of course
I'm sorry yeah
yeah
great
to just go higher and higher
yeah so the question is you're more
familiar with scrum and in scrum you
have a feedback loop called
retrospective to constantly improve your
environment or constantly at least once
per Sprint
that's the continuous Improvement part
then
um and how do you do that with combomb
to also continuously improve that that
uh that process that work in progress
and
um as I said in in common we don't have
explicitly other meetings than the
common meeting although in the the last
uh improvements of common and also in
the common books and the common uh
guides there are I think seven cadences
so there is there are more canises going
on so more feedback loops and that's
like uh your your your review meetings
and your risk meetings and strategy
meetings so there there are items in
there that is based on process
Improvement and we much look at it like
in Service delivery process so I think
most people who use ITIL or something
know what Service delivery is all about
and we've got some specific meetings in
that place but in essence what we think
as real lean people is that you should
not
continuously improve
every two weeks you should do it
constantly so we think that the common
meeting is a meeting to address what is
going on at the moment but after the
common meeting we should go into kazen
meetings to fix the problems we have and
if that's something that is impeding the
flow then that's the most important
thing to fix because if you have a flow
problem then you also have delivery
problems so the best thing to do with
with constantly improving is to have it
on a daily or constant basis so I would
rather see it constantly but because in
the west we are very bad with
retrospectives we do a lot of plan do
but check act We Leave Behind most of
the time so if you do the plan to check
act then
we we probably we use scrum because then
we at least do once every two weeks or
three weeks or four weeks do a real
Improvement and that's something we
forget in most of the environments so
therefore it's a good idea to implement
something like a retrospective Loop and
I would also suggest to do that bomb
but preferably we do it constantly every
day based on what the problems are at
that moment and then make room for it to
fix it
yeah
cool
development where you have
um I have to re recall the question for
the people listening in the Overflow
room of course so
um we see that kanban is coming from
more like the lean environment and lean
is more based on uh we we call it a
complicated domain where you've got a
recursive way of working so you've got a
standardized flow and then you want to
optimize that flow and if you go into
the um the the the environments we're
working software development there are
more complex so there are more changes
going on and it's more variable and
there we see more things like scrum
going on than than kanbum and the
question is do I see come on working in
those kind of environments also and
um for for me the most important thing
is that when when David created it came
from feature driven development it was
one of the agile methods when the Azure
Manifesto was written and he created at
both on that idea and the theory of
constraint of Goldwater the goal that's
part of the whole idea behind common and
the common we know from lean is with the
the small letter K and not the capital K
and we David created the the capital K
komb and that's come bomb for
evolutionary change system so it's it's
for more like in a complex system but I
agree that
um in essence the flow system I think
it's important in every flow workflow
environments but it doesn't really
consider that complexity that's where
where scrum is all about and have that
feedback loop also with the customer
but of course you can Implement you can
Implement scrum with combo I can if I
give if I give a compound training I
will say that to the to the crowd if I
do a scrum trading of course I won't but
if I say say it through common crowd I
say well scrum is just a specific
compound implementation with 13 rules
so the explicit policies we've got in
place in scrum are can also be done in a
compound system
um but kanban is delivering us the
possibility to get rid of them that's a
number of those rules that get it maybe
get in the way so the most important one
I think is to uh to cut between the
planning moment and the delivery moment
we don't have an iteration we can plan
whatever we want and we can deliver
whatever we want and I think that's
what's going on at the moment we've got
a continuous delivery pipelines and we
don't have to wait a Sprint to deliver
something of course and scrum is coming
along with that because they say you're
allowed to deliver more than once per
Sprint
but come on explicitly made it possible
to get rid of that iteration and make a
planning and delivery feedback loop on a
different level so I think
I think common is very useful usable in
production and development environments
the only thing is that you get less uh
less rules to work with
and therefore it's probably you need
some more maturity to put it into a good
practice and that's that's probably
difficulty so come on look simple but
therefore it isn't more simple to
implement it's more more difficult to
implement if you do it right if you want
to do it right
but I think that's the same with scrum
you can completely uh
uh create an environment that's not good
with scrum I want to call a different
world but yeah
is that okay yeah thank you
how do you identify
where a company stands and have they've
been at this point of stability for long
enough to be ready for the next step
yeah so the question is Kaizen is a lot
of small steps and how do you know if an
organization is already in that small
step think
yeah so
yeah yeah so and I think that's that's
also that's part of the so if you look
at the the Deming cycle the plan to
check egg Loop then we also have a
standardization step and I think that's
what's what's in the the common maturity
model that's what we call consolidation
so we have to look into uh the maturity
model and look at all the practices and
um indeed it's it's a good question to
uh to it's I think it's difficult for a
coach to know based on a book where they
are in this in the in the flow because
you don't know of course so I think this
is sensitivity this is uh fingerspit
single fool
um a good coach knows more than what's
in the book so so you can do a lot of
stuff based on feeling and talking with
people and those kind of things so
um this will help you find out if you're
in transition on what level of
consolidation in what level based on the
practices but you still have to think
and feel and talk and be a coach because
I'm not sure if you uh if you if you do
football or soccer or something like
that but in the Netherlands we had a we
had a coach who was tremendously good
with the the Dutch football team the
national football team and then he went
to Australia and he did some really good
stuff and then of South Korea he did
some good stuff into Russia and some
good stuff and they all got into the
first three of the world pretty much or
four and then he came back to the
Netherlands and he completely sucked at
that team it didn't work at all and it's
it's not because he didn't know what to
do
because he did it like yeah disenya of
of helping teams improve and it worked
very well and suddenly it didn't work so
it's not because he didn't know the book
but it just didn't work and that's also
something that we have to be aware of so
it's it's not only following the book
but it's also feeling what is the level
and where are they at the moment and and
then deciding what to do so I always if
there are people in here doing coaching
I always suggest Lee creating your own
blog post your blogging and always
Define this is my hypothesis I'm going
to do this and what will happen then I
think this and
um so I always try to revisit my
hypotheses and I know that in a complex
environment the hypothesis with
something that will work will not work
the next time the same the same way so
that's just something that you have to
be aware of
yeah
thank you
we've got six minutes if someone still
has a question
no
then uh oh yeah I'm sorry
yeah it's it's the lights
it'll take a stop and when the U.S an
edge coach actually coach the team to
stop at the certain level yeah
staying at that level and just refining
the practice at level four for instance
and yeah
yeah so your question is uh it looks
like the camera maturity model aims for
Nirvana level six
um but your question is is it also okay
to stop at a certain level like say
three or four and not go any further
because maybe going further maybe even
and I think that that's the case it
might even frustrate the teams because I
think level and I think it starts at
level four already you really need
leadership involvement and sponsorship
and if you go to five and six it's like
the higher level of strategic thinking
on leadership level and C Level and
therefore
it's not something that you really can
influence on the team level anymore so I
think it's a very good idea and that's
probably also that I've seen a lot is
that and I did myself is uh frustrating
the teams by telling them what what gold
is on the other side of the of the
rainbow and in Nirvana and they never
achieved it so they got really
frustrated about it because there was a
ceiling of management they couldn't pull
through so I think it's very good to uh
to also be aware that sometimes this is
enough and then uh and that I think that
might also be what you asked for and
then standardize on that level and then
the next step is going to be a
leadership change and not uh having
teams fight for more maturity because
that probably won't work so I think
you're completely right yeah thank you
yeah I I see a conforming knot so that's
good
cool
more questions
okay then uh thank you very much for
being here
um there is a common maturity book I'm
not going to market for it but just for
people who wanted to know more about it
you can also look it up at the kmm plus
website
um thanks thank you for being here I
hope it was interesting and I hope you
got something from it and that you will
put into practice and if you have any
questions also about kanban or other
agile things uh because all those
developers here I can talk about those
kind of things with you if you want me
yeah
okay have a good day thank you